Pope Francis is making his first public
appearance this morning amid calls to
resign over the church sex abuse scandal
this follows an explosive new claim by
Pennsylvania's Attorney General Josh
Shapiro told CBS this morning yesterday
the alleged cover-up involving
Pennsylvania's clergy stretched all the
way to the Vatican Shapiro did not
implicate the Pope specifically Seth
Doane is in Rome just outside st.
Peter's Square South good morning good
morning speaking just behind me earlier
today the Pope did talk about his
weekend trip to Ireland and the pain of
the sex abuse scandal there but he did
not specifically address the contents of
that controversial letter released
Sunday Pope Francis addressed those in
st. Peter's Square today we found some
struggling with their faith you don't
want to be open to by your faith really
it's made this is controversies made you
ashamed of your faith shame but it's
more of when other people of other
faiths when they're looking at you and
they're talking to you that's all they
know is what they're seeing on the news
that letter penned by a former top
Vatican diplomat called for the Pope's
resignation and alleged the pontiff
knowingly allowed a sex abuser Cardinal
Theodore McCarrick
to continue operating at the highest
ranks of the church unpunished Monsignor
Carla Vega knows 11 page letter included
sweeping conservative ideological
commentary including railing against
homosexuals in the church vegan oh did
not provide any documents to support his
accusations that at least 35 church
leaders were involved in covering up
abuse while many bishops have condemned
vegan Oh others have called for an
investigation Monsignor Carol Castile
has worked for 7 Pope's in his known
vegan Oh since he was a young seminarian
he's certainly an honest person and he's
done his job well and I think he he felt
that he had to talk vegan O's letter
comes in the wake of that grand jury
report that exposed 300 pedophile
priests and 1000 plus victims in
Pennsylvania the state attorney general
appeared on CBS this morning I can tell
you that there is facts there is
evidence that takes this cover
and what occurred in Pennsylvania
directly to the Vatican the director of
the Holy See press office told us if the
Attorney General was discussing
something outside of the report they
would have to wait to see those details
before making any comment and Italian
media is reporting today the close
associates of Pope Francis say he is
saddened but Gail is not considering
resignation all right to be continued
for sure thank you very much Seth Doane
reporting from Rome